Let us delve deeper into the realm of the mitochondria
It is best for me
Let's take a look back at what the mitochondria are
Then we will go deeper
In their installation
Think about the cell
Specifically the eukaryotic cell
This is the cellular membrane
When people talk about eukaryotic cells
The first thing that comes to mind is nucleic acid
Located in the cell nucleus
Let us draw the cellular membrane of the nucleus
If this is the membrane of the nucleus
Here DNA will be DNA
Let's draw DNA
When we talk about the eukaryotic cell
We do not just talk about the nucleus inside the cell membrane
But also other organelles in the inner membrane
It comes second in the composition of the membrane
It is very important for the cell
The mitochondria
Let us paint the mitochondria here
I will talk more
I will talk more about the winding lines
In the mitochondria
They are actually a bit bigger
Of the cartoons in the book, as we will learn
Since we have more
From the developed cartoons of what is happening in
Inside the cell, but in reality
Do not answer all our questions
But you certainly learned from them,
I will explain the picture here, this mitochondria
It is a collection
And if we talk about one of them
We call it the mitochondria
It is the singular name of mitochondria
You may have already known him,
In the past or through another file in the Academy
They are called cell power plants.
I'll write it that way
ATP power plants
If you watch videos about ATP power plants
Or cellular respiration or other videos,
I will often talk about how ATP is the base currency
Of energy in the cell when the ATP is in a position
Adenosine triphosphate
If fired one of the phosphate molecules
They will produce energy
This is what your body does to do some work
Such as movement and thinking to the rest of things
This is beneficial to our bodies,
Let us imagine the importance of mitochondria
Where it produces energy when the cell needs to do different things
So we'll find more mitochondria
In the muscle cells and cells that are used
More energy.
And now before I talk about the composition of the mitochondria
I will talk a bit about her amazing past
Because we consider the cell the most important unit in life
This is true as stated in cell theory,
But in most theories it has become widespread
In how the mitochondria reach our cells
It is through our ancestors
Any of our ancestors to our own mitochondria
They are free and independent microorganisms
They are microorganisms such as bacteria
Where these bacteria lived alone
They are good at producing and processing energy
They were good at other things too,
But at the stage of their development in the past
It was devoured by cells of the ancestors
Instead of being torn apart and turned into pieces
Or digest and eat
"They are stuck and part of the cell
"She continued to survive
"Because they are able to help produce glucose
Or help generate more energy than things. "
These cells were able to live
Through the formation of a symbiotic relationship which gave them a place to live
Both mitochondria and ancient mitochondria
Thus the mitochondria lived the ancestor
And then through the process of natural selection,
So we are associated with it
We are now linked to eukaryotic cells
With the presence of mitochondria,
So the whole idea is an organism
Coexistence with another organism at the cell level
It is mind boggling, however
I will stop talking about this thing and start talking now
About current time and talk about
Composition of mitochondria
At first I will draw a simplified drawing
I will draw a cross section of the mitochondria
Here is the cross-section.
As if we made half.
Well, let's see what we've painted here
This is the outer membrane
This is the outer membrane.
Let us write its title.
External membrane.
All these membranes I will draw,
Will be a double layer of phosphate fat
So if you would like to zoom in from here,
I will enlarge this part,
We will see a double layer of phosphate fat.
So we have
Water-loving heads are directed outward
The tails are water-loving and directed to the inside
So
You see it this way,
All double layers of phosphate fat
But it contains not only phosphorus
All of these membranes contain a group of proteins
Which means that cells are complex in structure
Yet the mitochondria are amazing organelles,
They are its sub-structure
They have a plethora of proteins,
Enzymes are also an essential part of membranes
They are able to organize what is going on
In and out of these organelles.
One of these proteins is located in the outer membrane
Of the Mitochondria and are called Burrens
The protein is not only present in the mitochondria,
It is a type of conjunctive protein
Its composition allows it to form channels
In the outer membrane
So I do my best to paint them in the best way possible
Here is Burns
It's a special thing for Pourines she does not allow
For the large particles through which,
While small molecules such as sugar and ions can cross from
Through Bournez.
So the concentration of your ions
And also,
Small particles tend to focus
To be identical on both sides of the membrane,
And also on the side of the outer membrane.
This is not the only employee cover
In the mitochondria.
Also we have inner casing
I will paint it in yellow.
We also have internal membrane
I will draw it as described in the book first
Then I'll talk a little about him,
I think it's not exactly the right shape,
But here we have the inner membrane,
Internal membrane,
These folds are found inside the inner membrane
To increase surface area
It is very important
For the inner membrane
Where the electron chain transfer process takes place
It mainly occurs via these membranes.
So we need this extra space on the surface
So you can transfer more electron
These folds have names.
So if we talk about one of them,
If we talk about one of these pleats,
You talk about custom,
If you talk about more than one of them,
Then you will give it by customs,
Sometimes you utter
The custom is to collect a custom punch.
They are just folds of the inner cover
We repeat here that the inner membrane
Contains two phosphorous layers.
Inside the membrane,
There is a vacuum between the internal membrane and the outer membrane
You can guess what it is called
The vacuum is called the space between the membranes
It is a normal name, space or space between the two membranes
And because of the porenz
Small particles concentrated
On the inner and outer membrane
In the mitochondria,
In cytozole,
This concentration is uneven
Because the internal membrane does not contain porens
So the concentration of molecules varies
This is necessary on both sides
For electron transmission series.
The electron transport chain really culminates
With hydrogen and hydrogen ion gradient
Where they are built on both sides
Then flow down this gradient through the protein
The enzyme called ATP is called ATP
We'll talk about it later in this video
Or in another video
Let us end our conversation about the different parts
In the mitochondria
In our cell membrane
This area here is called filling.
I will use another color
this is
Filling
The filling is called because it contains
Greater concentration of protein
In fact it is more viscous than cytosol
Located in the outside
The mitochondria.
Let's write the filling here.
When we talk cellular respiration,
Cellular respiration has several stages.
We'll talk first about glycolysis
Glycolase appears on the cytozole
If glycolysis occurs in cytozole.
Glycolysis
The other important stage in the process of cellular respiration.
A cycle of citric acid
Also known as the Karps course
Which gets in the filling.
If the course of Karpas
You get in the Matrix
And then the electronic transport chain
It is responsible for producing
Most of the ATP, which occurs through proteins
Located in the internal membrane
Or who is in the customs here.
We're done now.
It is an amazing part of the mitochondria,
We said we thought it was a breed
From the ancestors of free living objects
And even be the ancestors of free living objects
They need to get some information
In order to transmit genetic information
It has already been shown that the mitochondria have
Its own genetic information.
They have mitochondrial DNA
They do not have only one copy of it, but often,
There are several copies of it
They are in the form of rings and are very similar to bacterial DNA
In fact they have many things in common
With bacterial DNA so we believe
That the ancestors of the mitochondria live independently
It may have been a form of bacteria or has been associated with it
Somehow.
If these
Mitochondrial DNA rings
If most of the DNA is inside you
Comes from the DNA found in the nucleus, and also you have
Little DNA in the mitochondria
Interestingly, DNA is present in the mitochondria
You have inherited it
By your mother, because when you fertilize the egg
The human egg contains tons of mitochondria
As you can see here, I do not draw all the things that exist
In a human egg.
It has a nucleus as in the drawing.
The nuclear animal has mitochondria.
You can imagine in need of some energy to be able
To win the competition and reach the egg
And fertilize the egg
But the current theory says that all or most of these mitochondria
Digested or dissolved as soon as they enter
Of the egg
The egg itself contains many mitochondria
So the DNA in your mitochondria
It is from your mother or in particular coming from your mother's side
It actually uses mitochondrial DNA
When people talk about the Yves dynasty
They track ratios to get
On a common mum,
They look at mitochondrial DNA
It is very exciting for you.
As I said before
The mitochondria have their own DNA
And because it has DNA
It has its own RNA synthesis capability
Its own mitochondrial reybose
But it does not synthesize the whole protein
Located in the mitochondria
Many of them are compounded
Or encoded through DNA in the nucleus
In fact it is synthesized outside the mitochondria
And then turn to the mitochondria,
The mitochondria are wonderful things
Where they are creatures living together
In the cells and are able to copy themselves
I find all these things perplexing.
But anyway
I said beforehand that this is a book model
Because it turned out that when I look
For microscopic mitochondria
He seems to stand by the book in the form
Pleats, these customs are part of folds,
But when we managed to get to
Imagine a developer lost it turned out to us
They are not just simple folds
Where the inner membrane is essentially a perforator
Inside the filling it turned out that
It has a small vial reaching the vacuum
In the inside of the custom to the inner membrane
So I want to think about it until I understand,
I looked at the book and said
"Yes it is obvious that this is the mitochondria"
"And here are the plants ATP energy"
But there is still a collection of picture research
To understand exactly how it works
And also how to install them
This is Pavel's model where you see the best
Enter and exit from several aspects.
In fact, it has not been accepted
As a conceptual model for the composition of the mitochondria.
Something like this where
Here we have a cross-sectional model
For example, if you draw a cross-section here
Where here
The outer membrane and inner membrane are painted
I will draw these small channels here
To the vacuum within the norms.
In fact this is the most acceptable scenario now,
So I want you to be grateful
Where in the neighborhoods when you read something from the book
You will say, "People have discovered
"All these things" but people are still thinking about them
"How does this structure work?
"How is the structure really?"
"And how in fact let this earth,
"This wonderful past does all this
"This is what needs to be done"